[Musique]
leur livre les condos tadic lui-même il
acquiesça catholique à kétou perdu on a
dit qu
il voulait dire notre colère sont mortes
wado relate
les munichois fratelli méchoui canada
nervis secousse
bonjour mesdames et messieurs alors
c'est fait vous l'avez entendu le pape
françois a présenté des excuses a
demandé pardon aussi pour les gestes
posés par l'église dans les pensionnats
pour autochtones du canada le pape a
aussi annoncé sa visite prochaine au
pays certains évoquent d'ailleurs la
fête de sainte-anne ça se passe à la fin
du mois de juillet donc ça pourrait être
très rapide nous vous présentons ce
matin au cours des prochaines heures une
émission spéciale donc sur la conclusion
de cette semaine qui est historique pour
les peuples autochtones du canada au
vatican tout de suite ont beau se
rendent d'ailleurs à rome où se trouve
notre envoyé spécial mathieu boyer qui a
suivi d'ailleurs toute cette semaine
importante bonjour mathieu
bonjour à tous les peuples autochtones
qui attendait ses excuses depuis
plusieurs années on le sait
oui effectivement il faut donner du
contexte tout seul parce que c'est ça
date pas d'hier cette demande des
peuples autochtones de recevoir des
excuses dans l'histoire canadienne on
estime que 150 mille enfants autochtones
qu'à trier qui ont été arrachés à leur
famille envoyés de force dans les
pensées là qui étaient gérés à 70 pour
sa part des congrégations catholiques
l'euro 2000 catholique était vraiment
prépondérant dans les pensionnats le
rapport vérité réconciliation je vous
rappelle estimé qu'en quatre et six
mille enfants ont perdu la vie dans les
pensionnats les gens ne savaient depuis
longtemps que des enfants aller au
pensionnat mais n'en revenait jamais y
eut cependant un éveil collectif au
canada l'an dernier en mai plus
précisément quand les sépultures de 215
enfants ont été découvertes sur le
terrain de l'ancien pensionnat pour
autochtone de kamloops sas a permis
d'accélérer si vous voulez la discussion
sur le rôle des pensionnats sur le rôle
de l'église catholique ou ci s'est
découvert de camelot elle a aussi
accéléré les choses pour organiser la
visite qui a eu lieu cette semaine elle
était déjà en branle mais disons que ça
a été vraiment un catalyseur cette
découverte de camelot ton qu'on se
retrouve ici à rome cette semaine pour
que le pape finalement vous l'avez
entendu présente ses excuses
le pape françois toute la semaine à
écouter délégué a eu plus de quatre
heures d'audience avec une délégation
inuits métis et des premières nations
vous donnez un peu de contexte c'est
énorme dans l'agenda du pape sauf quatre
heures lorsqu'il reçoit par exemple le
premier ministre canadien justin trudeau
ou d'autres chefs de gouvernement ou
d'état il leur accorde généralement
moins d'une heure ça vous dit toute
l'importance d'accorder le vatican cet
esprit de réconciliation de tête
derrière de la semaine organisée par la
conférence des évêques s'étaient marcher
ensemble vers la guérison et la
réconciliation
alors après 4 heures d'écouté le pape a
finalement pris la parole prononcer les
mots que voulait en fait entendre les
peuples autochtones du canada le pape
disait le traitement de ces enfants dans
les pensionnats ne correspond pas du
tout aux messages d'amour et d'ouverture
enseignée par jésus-christ on peut
écouter là dessus un extrait de
l'allocution du pape françois
et provoque les pergolas vélo que je
ressens également de la honte sur
vologne je voudrais pas les jeux sans
garantie de la douleur et de la remontée
inattendue
face au rôle que divers catholique aux
responsabilités donc particulier ceux
qui ont des responsabilités éducatives
ont joué dans tout ce qu'il faut appeler
c'est que bien fait l'écho dans les
habits jabot 6ème la main comme salut
nazi dans le manque de respect envers la
précédente et assorti qui la bourse très
costaude a
dit wade envers vos valeurs spirituelles
monsieur plusieurs souhaitaient ses
excuses c'est vrai mais il ya beaucoup
d'autochtones aussi qu'ils souhaitaient
que le pape vienne au canada peut-être
même se rendent d'ailleurs sur les lieux
d ancien pensionnat et l'a confirmé
qu'il va le faire est bientôt là
bientôt le pape a dit dans son discours
catherine j'ai hâte de vous revoir chez
vous en territoire autochtone alors le
pape qui répondait si vous vouliez à une
autre devant la paix celle des excuses
de confirmer une visite on n'a pas les
dates précises encore mais tout de suite
après l'audience phil fontaine qui était
leur lancée celle de l'assemblée des
premières nations dit écoutez ça devrait
se faire cet été c'est l'analyse qu'en
fait monsieur fontaine on attendra bien
sûr la confirmation officielle mais on
sent l'empressement au sein les l'un qui
a été pris cette semaine ici à rome
l'église le continuer sur cet élan et le
fait donc le dit me rendent chez vous au
canada les peuples d'automne voulez ou
bien sûr que le pape vienne aussi
présenté des excuses chez eux devant
leur famille en territoire autochtone
qu'on est à la ken loach et deux
semaines la chef dudi sela baquet poste
important que le pape puisse dire
s'adresser dans leurs ancêtres de
paroisse ou de réception à quel point
c'était l'endroit tout indiqué pour
entendre le pape on écoute encore là
dessus le pack françois solo felice ti
bénéfique à aller un coup je suis
heureux de profiter au cours de votre
culture en visitant vos territoires où
il ya votre culture et votre famille je
n'irai pas en hiver mais je me rendrai
au canada
où là je pourrai plus vous exprimer ma
fraternité ma solidarité amitié je vous
assure ma prière ces cours intel a payé
évoquant la bénédiction du créateur sur
vous sur vos familles et surtout
communauté sous les bourses famille et
ce n'est votre commune et à
les métis les inuits et les premières
nations ont pu rencontrer le pape
françois cette semaine au total près de
200 personnes pour cette grande
délégation et on va les entendre tout à
l'heure en point de presse officielle
mais déjà on a des réactions ces gens là
sont soulagé ému même
oui parce qu'ils ont tenu 4 et d'une
mêlée de presse tout de suite après leur
rencontre avec le pape ici sur la place
saint pierre on sentait le soulagement
on sentait une certaine
un moment là on sentait vraiment
l'émotion oui ici sur la place
saint-pierre beaucoup d'émotion simo la
tant attendue en fait ils ont été
prononcées les délégués les
représentants tokten insiste cependant
pour dire c'est une première étape une
très belle première étape il y en aura
d'autres si le début de quelque chose
qu'on a vécu ici à rome et non pas la
fin d'un chapitre vraiment là-dessus et
couteau tout de suite à des
représentants tonnes qui était avec le
pape
unique au canada
exact
alors voilà le pape a présenté ses
excuses catherine c'est pas exagéré de
dire qu'on a assisté plus tôt
aujourd'hui un moment historique je
termine en vous disant que aussi
historique soit il le moment le pape
françois avait déjà présenté des excuses
récemment à des peuples autochtones en
amérique du sud en bois liées notamment
au mexique aussi on sent que par
françois veut faire les choses à sa
manière faire ce que d'autres papes dont
faure voulu faire auparavant les
délégations étaient venus 6 en 2009
pedro saez ne s'étaient pas excusés
cette fois ci les plus hot hot hot
repart de rome avec enfin ce qu'ils
étaient venus chercher
mathieu on vous laisse mais on va se
reparlent assurément petit peu plus tard
parce que je le disais il y aura point
de presse officielle aussi de cette
délégation alors à tout à leur merci
au revoir
alors pour nous accompagner dans cette
émission spéciale pour mieux comprendre
aussi comme le disait mathieu peut-être
bon de ne pas les attentes mais aussi le
caractère historique et la suite de ses
excuses de ses gestes posés par le père
françois je serai très bien accompagné
ce matin mes invités vous les voyez
isabelle picard ethnologue et membre de
la nation des hurons wendat et alain
prokin le spécialiste des questions
religieuses chercheur au centre d août
et d'interprétation des nouvelles
recherches ducroire bonjour à vous merci
d'être avec nous
isabelle je vais commencer avec vous
parce que bon on l'a dit au cours de
cette semaine les mots qui seront
prononcées par le pape françois sont
très importants le choix des mots on a
entendu aussi qu'il a exprimée de la
honte même ce matin parlez-moi de ce
qu'a dit le pape ce françois ce matin
effectivement pour moi le choix des mots
faisait partie des excuses parce que ça
devait être senti et je pense que i le
prix les bons mots quand il parle
d'humiliation quand il parlait de honte
on sent que vraiment il comprend il l'a
entendu et c'était très important pour
les premiers peuples pour la délégation
mais pour tous les survivants aussi
qu'ils sont au canada
ce n'était pas anodin donc moi
j'attendais beaucoup de ça et je pense
qu'il a répondu à ses attentes par les
mots qu'il a utilisée qui était
culpabilisant pour l'église en grande
partie d'ailleurs et le fait même
d'avoir exprimé la honte ça aussi c'est
quand même à souligner non
oui oui absolument
il a il dit que les valeurs qui avaient
été disons projeté à dans les
pensionnats n'était pas les valeurs de
l'église catholique alors ça pour moi
c'était reconnaître la vérité et
beaucoup de survivants je parlais avec
un aîné ce matin anishnabe et il me
disait que cette reconnaissance de la
vérité c'était ce qu'il a attendez donc
les mots forts des mots lourds de sens
des mots se sentent si c'était vraiment
le message je crois que le pape devait
livrer ces protéines ça a repris
plusieurs papes et plusieurs années
avant qu'on peut s'entendre ses moules à
ses regrets pour les regrets mais les
excuses et regrets a été exprimée par
benoît 16 on y reviendra est ce qu'un
autre pape que le pack françois aurait
pu faire ça va jean paul ii aurait pu le
faire - lorsque jean paul ii était le
premier patch c'est vraiment excusé
s'est excusé de quoi il s'est excusé de
tout ce qui est arrivé aux peuples
africains de toutes les les esclaves qui
ont été faits et qui ont été transportés
et ça a été fait par des catholiques
donc c'est le premier qui le fait et
c'est le premier qui était censé de
l'assaut et cantine ou canadore 1920 il
est d'abord revenu à 81 capes il y est
revenu par la suite en 87 déjà 87
parlait d'une forme de réconciliation
avec des premières nations ils font
marcher ensemble et ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui c'est le pape françois qui
il faut marcher ensemble il faut
construire des ponts et là évidemment
parlé on a bien entendu isabelle parler
de ce qui est arrivé dans des spas
saunas ou on a saccagé pratiquement la
culture des premières nations et il est
d'arriver en direct et il faut s'excuser
il ya même parler des thèmes qui sont
chers au pape de parler du diable c'est
le diable qui étaient là et l'eau il
faut reconstruire et il donne et demande
aux évêques canadiens de reconstruire
parce que c'est pas simplement de faire
des excuses les excuses étant le premier
pas maintenant il faut y aller de
l'avant et il faut construire avec les
premières et ça on a beaucoup entendu
cette semaine louis les excuses les mots
mais ensuite il faut passer à l'action
aux abeilles piquées relation va
commencer par cette visite au canada
sans doute mais l'église canadienne
aussi pour ne vienne avec vous à ce
propos qu'il va avoir un rôle à jouer
mais pendant cette visite la
caisse quoi s'attendent les peuples
autochtones
oui c'est une grande question évidemment
ils s'attendent à voir des excuses je
dirais plus plus longue d'ailleurs le
peuple dira qu'ils allaient qu'il allait
mieux faire ses excuses quand ils les
lettres en sol canadien mais je pense
qu'ils s'attendent à des actions
concrètes par exemple l'accès aux
archives de l'église
bon oui voilà qui va permettre aux
inuits aux métis et aux premières
nations entre autres d'identifier les
dépouiller qu'on a retrouvé là en
commençant avec avec kamloops en mai
dernier mais de les retrouver presque
2002 s'est dépouillé anonyme donc on
veut avoir un accès aussi à toutes ces
archives là donc ça serait évidemment un
des éléments qu'on a beaucoup entendu de
la part de monsieur fontaine entre
autres mais d'autres délégués et
d'autres survivants dont sept actions
concrètes qui permettraient de panser
les plaies je pense un peu d'aller un
peu plus loin pour les premières nations
les métis et désigner ce profit est ce
que vous pensez que le pape doit se
rendre à kamloops justement sur le lieu
de ses peintures là je vois que pas le
choix parce que premièrement au lieu de
donner symboliquement comme cadeau à
porte bébé et un porte bébé c'est clair
qu'on parle des enfants qui ont été
enterrés dans ces fosses là où des
tombes individuelles temps camelous qu'à
ma rivale donc il est clair au lieu de
donner des mocassins de sa grandeur pour
venez foulée des pieds et en plus
aujourd'hui un lieu donné des raquettes
pour marcher dans la neige donc c'est
certain qu'ils vont venir ici c'est
certain qu'il va aller dans des
pensionnats où il va y avoir ou des
enfants sont malheureusement été
enterrés sans être retourner sur leur
terre natale on verra avec les premières
nations avec les familles si on retourne
ses cordes sur leur terre natale mais il
ya des communautés qui le désirent donc
c'est tout ce qui s'en vient faire ici
c'est important et comme le disait belle
il faut ouvrir les archives des archers
c'est complexe on est des archives dans
les communautés religieuses les eaux
bleues ont dit oui à vos vrais nos
archives qui sont déjà au canada on
voudrait celles qui sont à rome est
lassé de voir les archives ou sont
instituées pour donner un exemple 5 les
diocèses du grand nord canadien et si ce
dernier diocèse ont quitté le giron du
vatican seulement 2016 parce qu'avant il
relevait directement de la congrégation
sur l'évangélisation qui pour le pape
françois vous devez d'un congrégation
congrégation c'est le ministère le plus
important à rome au mois de juin
prochain dont il est certain que des
archives cet endroit là puis
possiblement des archis sacramentelle
parce que les archives sacramentelle
c'est quoi on a atterri telle personne
fait d'être un tel endroit cette
personne était baptisé cette personne a
été confirmée donc ce n'est pas
simplement sommet les archives de ce que
des prêtres ont dit à l'époque on sait
qu'on a des archives de ce que des prêts
de s'exprimer déjà en 15/100 11 en
amérique du sud ou encore au mexique ou
en république dominicaine on a déjà ça
donc il doit avoir des archives de près
cou dévalent qui étaient là et qui
dénoncent cette situation là c'est pas
simplement de retrouver les corses qui
fondamentale mais aussi de savoir
qu'est-ce que les religieux et prêtres
des religieuses pensée qu'est ce que
c'est pas si j'entendais fait le
fontaine qui étaient là aussi lui
lorsque benoit 16 avait exprimé ses
regrets il a dit bon ça a été long mais
ça s'est fait par étapes est-ce que
d'après vous la découverte justement
entre autres à kamloops mais aussi de
ses autres sépultures au canada ça
accélérer le processus pour cette
rencontre qui a finalement eu lieu puis
cette visite qui va avoir lieu au cours
des prochains mois
c'est du chêne toujours
avec sûreté c'est déjà le premier
ministre du canada monsieur justin
trudeau avait ajouté le pape directement
sur la question des pensionnats
autochtones et s'était faite le 2 ou 3
ans conserver le fameux rapport vérité
réconciliation
dont ce qui est certain c'est que cette
demande de monsieur trudeau aide
énormément le déplacement du pape ici
parce que toute la question des coûts de
sécurité parce que déplacer le peuple ça
coûte énormément au niveau de la
sécurité est souvent les celle de
certaines régions du monde s'unissent
pour de bon comment pas financer
l'activité du pape on va faire une quête
spéciale est mais là comme le
gouvernement canadien invite du rectum
arabe de pas on va sauver dans les coûts
et dans l'organisation du dps match
plein mais il est certain que le peuple
pas le choix il doit aller en territoire
ou à ma rivale ou à kamloops ou encore
chez les inuit en eau parce que les unes
ou est on des revendications très
précises ils ont demandé le retour du
père et voir qui a agressé sexuellement
des enfants et qui est actuellement en
travaux
pardonnez moi vous allez terminer
isabelle
c'est le délai un des fois j'en et à
distance il faut quand même comprendre
isabelle j'ai entendu cette semaine à
plusieurs reprises on sait on s'est un
peu passée cette souffrance-là de
génération en génération chez les
peuples autochtones
j'imagine que les aînés les survivants
ne voit pas ça de la même manière que
les jeunes ont tout ce qui se passe en
ce moment
c'est drôle parce que ce matin je vous
le disais je parlais avec un survivant
donc anishnabe qui a eu 75 ans et
j'entendais beaucoup de sagesse alors
que les jeunes j'entends un peu plus de
colère nourrissent d'impatience c'est
peut-être le propre de la jeunesse aussi
mais quand même il y avait une réaction
qui était différente mais qui était je
trouve
senti qu'ils étaient sages comme je le
dis donc on parle d'un début de quelque
chose pour les survivants qui sont plus
âgés
les jeunes générations l'ont vécue de
façon différente parce que ça s'est
passé comme vous le dites de génération
en génération dans le conflit
oui mais on a quand même senti parce que
ce sont nos parents qui n'ont pas eu de
modèle parental et donc ont le sentiment
ou comment enfin on a aussi senti toutes
ses pertes les pertes de la culture des
coutumes de la langue donc tout ce qui
avait été enlevé à l'état du pensionnat
donc dans les années où pour le québec
dans les années 50 60 70
on leur ressenti et aujourd'hui on est
en train de rebâtir tout ça ensemble et
ça demande énormément d'efforts et on 5
lui je pense dès les plus jeunes ra sont
aussi dans tout ce processus de guérison
que vivent aussi les survivants qui sont
d'une autre génération vous avez un pic
à raleigh prochaine vous restez là on va
les réécouter si on veut une partie de
ce discours du pape françois ça s'est
passé un peu plus tôt évidemment au
vatican
merci
pour votre présence et pour les prières
que nous avons présentée
je suis suis reconnaissant d'être venu à
rome en dépit des difficultés causées
par la pandémie
ces derniers jours j'ai écouté vos
témoignages avec la plus grande
attention
je les ai portés dans la réflexion et
dans la prière
en leur présentant votre situation
je vous suis reconnaissant d'avoir
ouvert et si votre coeur et dans ce
désir vous avez exprimé le désir de
cheminée de marcher ensemble
alors je reprend plusieurs des aspects
qui m'ont touché je reprends par une
expression qui vient de votre sagesse et
qui n'est pas simplement une façon de
dire mais une façon de voir la vie
il faut penser aux sept générations à
venir quand on doit prendre une décision
aujourd'hui
c'est une parole de sagesse une parole
éclairante
très souvent aujourd'hui on cherche des
solutions immédiates sans penser à
l'avenir et aux générations qui viennent
au contraire le lien entre les aînés et
les jeunes est indispensable
cela permet de préserver les souvenirs
et de protéger l'identité et contre ses
protégés la mémoire et l'identité
l'humanité s'améliore
et j'ai remarqué une très belle image
ces derniers jours comme les branches de
l'arbre qui pointent dans les
différentes directions vous avez
traversé différentes saisons
vous avez été exposés à de forts vents
mais vous êtes en quête de fortes
racines que vous avez su garder scène et
c'est pour cela que vous continuez à
porter du fruit parce que les branches
qui se pointent vers leur hausse
s'appuie sur de profondes racines
j'aimerais mentionner certains fruits
qui doivent être reconnus et appréciés
d'abord le soin de la terre
que vous ne prenez pas comme bien
exploité mais comme un don du ciel
et là le souvenir des ancêtres aussi et
qui vous guide et qui vous permettra de
vivre que votre existence
dans un tissu de relations avec le
créateur avec la communauté humaine avec
les espèces vivantes et avec la maison
commune que nous habitons tout cela
vous amène à rechercher une harmonie
intérieure extérieure à cultiver l'amour
de la famille avoir un sens très profond
de la communauté
[Musique]
relevons les richesses particulières de
volant de votre addition de vos cultures
qui s'expriment dans des oeuvres d'art
des zones akin à pernes partiellement à
vous mais il faut partie du patrimoine
commun de l'humanité
votre arbre qui porte du fruit a subi
une tragédie que vous m'avez raconter
ces jours-ci
celle du déracinement
[Musique]
votre façon de vivre un territoire donné
était attaqué par la décolonisation et
qui a arraché plusieurs d'entre vous à
votre milieu de vie pour essayer de vous
imposer une autre mentalité ainsi votre
identité et votre culture ont été
blessées plusieurs familles ont été
séparées
d'enfants ont été victimes de c'est une
action
qui
pensaient que le progrès pourrait venir
de la colonisation
idéologiques au lieu de respecter la vie
des pauvres
c'est quelque chose qui souviennent
encore aujourd'hui à différents niveaux
cette colonisation idiot logique
plusieurs organisations politiques
idéologiques et économiques
se font encore aujourd'hui dans le monde
poussé par la recherche du profit et au
mépris des populations de la tradition
de leur histoire et de la maison commune
de la création et ni malheureusement
encore aujourd'hui cette mentalité
coloniale est trop répandue
et dont nous les uns les autres à la
surmonter
à travers vos voix j'ai pu
partager avec une grande tristesse les
c'est de souffrance de privation de
discrimination les différentes formes
d'abus que plusieurs d'entre vous
avaient subi en particulier dans les
pensionnats
et il est
consternant de
voir
comment on a exploité le sentiment
d'infériorité
d'essayer de couper les racines
personnelles des personnes avec toutes
les concéquences personnelle et
communautaire que cela a eu et continue
d'avoir aujourd'hui
des traumatismes
je lui mets qui sont devenus des
traumatismes
intergénérationnel
tout cela a suscité en moi deux
sentiments d'abord l'indignation
et la honte
l'indignation parce qu'il est injuste
d'accepter le mal est encore pire de s'y
habituer
comme ici c'était une dynamique
à laquelle on ne pouvait résister kinois
de l'histoire non je ressens profonde
indignation et il est indispensable de
syndiqués pour pouvoir résoudre les
problèmes nous le voyons ces jours ci à
propos de la guerre on ne doit jamais
sacrifier le souvenir du passé au nom de
certains progrès
et je ressens aussi de la honte je
voulais dit et je le répète
il ressent de la douleur et de la honte
pour le fait que les catholiques et
catholiques y avait des responsabilités
d'enseignement
ont contribué à ce qui vous a blessé à
ce manque de respect à ces abus par
rapport à votre identité à votre culture
et par rapport même à vos valeurs
spirituelles
tout cela est contraire à l'évangile de
jésus
je réprouve le comportement de ses
membres de l'église catholique et j'en
demande pardon à dieu et je veux vous
dire de tout coeur que je suis
profondément meurtri
et je m'unis à mes confrères les évêques
du canada
pour vous présenter nos excuses
évidemment on ne peut pas transmettre
les contenus de la foi d'une façon qui
soit contraire à la foi elle-même
jésus nous enseigner à accueillir et
mais à chaque rire et à ne pas juger
il est terrible de voir qu au nom même
de la fois on donne un contre-témoignage
à l'évangile
cela
ne fait qu'accroître en moi le besoin
que je ressens que
je me rappelle ce que les créateurs nous
dit dans les premiers livres de la bible
après deux fautes ils le demandent à
l'homme ou et que tu es un peu après et
lui pose une autre question
doivent et au fait où est ton frère
où es tu où est ton frère ce sont des
questions que nous devons nous reposer
constamment ce sont les questions
essentielles qui se posent à notre
conscience car nous ne devons pas
oublier que nous sommes sur la terre
pour y préserver le caractère sacré de
la vie et que nous sommes donc les
gardiens de nos frères de tous les
peuples qui sont nos frères en même
temps je pense avec gratitude à beaucoup
de croyances généreux qui au nom de la
foi qui avec respect avec
amour
accueilli votre témoignage
dans l'esprit de l'évangile je vois
aussi la dimension que vous avez à cette
année la grand-mère de cesu
cette année
je voudrais être avec vous pour célébrer
la fête de sainte-anne
aujourd'hui nous devons reconstruire une
alliance entre les grands-parents et les
petits enfants entre les anciens et les
jeunes pour se situer une plus grande
unité au sein de la famille humaine
chers frères et soeurs
je me souhaite que les rencontres de ces
jours-ci pu s'ouvrir une chemin
intérieur
plus nous donne du courage et steam
notre engagement au niveau local qu'il
puisse lancer un processus de guérison
mais cela demande et actions concrètes
un esprit de fraternité
et j'encourage les évêques les
catholiques à continuer de faire n'est
pas pour la recherche de la vérité pour
promouvoir la guérison des blessures et
pour promouvoir aussi la réconciliation
un chemin qui permettra de redécouvrir
et de revitaliser votre culture
j'exprime l'amour le respect de l'église
et notre attention particulière pour
votre tradition authentique
je tiens à vous dire que l'église est de
votre côté veut continuer de cheminer
avec vous
le dialogue est la clé pour pouvoir
partager et les évêques du canada ont
dit clairement leur détermination à
continuer de cheminer avec vous
ce chemin renouvelée qui soit féconde
constructeurs ou des projets communs
pourront vous aider
mais j'ai très chers amis j'étais en
russie par vos paroles et encore plus
par votre témoignage
vous avez apporté ici à rome sans se
vivent de vos communautés
je serais heureux de pouvoir vous
rencontrer de nouveau en allant visiter
vos terres là où vivent vos familles et
je n'irai pas dire en hiver par contre
je vous dis donc au revoir au revoir au
canada aux jeux pourraient mieux vous
exprimer ma proximité et ma solidarité
et je vous assure de mes prières et je
croque la muse du créateur sur vous sur
vos familles et sur vos communautés
et j'aimerais je ne voudrais pas
terminer sans vous et j'adresse un mois
vous ou à vous les évêques merci merci
pour votre courage merci
dans l'humilité
c'est dans l'humilité que se révèle
l'esprit du seigneur face à des
histoires comme celle que nous avons
écouté l'humiliation de l'église et
fécondité merci pour votre courage et
merci à vous toutes l'air vous tous
cette semaine au vatican est vraiment
une semaine historique et
particulièrement ce discours du pape
françois que vous avez entendu dans
lequel il s'est excusé et je vais
reprendre ses mots il a dit je m'unis
aux évêques du canada pour vous
présenter nos excuses les excuses qui
était évidemment attendu par les
survivants entre autres des pensionnats
pour autochtones mon prochain invité et
un seul à jean charles piétacho chef de
la communauté ea nous des caniches it
bonjour
cui est ce que ces mots-là du pape cette
honte qu'il dit avoir ressenti est ce
que
ça vous satisfait vous en tant que
survivant
un tacle sur milan en tant que chef la
communauté
écoutez il faut il faut reconnaître chez
journée quand même importante pour tout
l'ensemble des premières nations au pays
et
reconnaît aussi travail extraordinaire
des délégations des trois délégations
qui ont aussi la semaine voici qu'un et
réexpliqué de ce que nous nous savions
depuis plusieurs années est ce que nous
demandions dans le passé depuis l'avenue
du parc en 1984 jean paul 2 venue de
benoît un
2009 est
écouté aujourd'hui c'est quand même une
belle journée pour le moment moi ce qui
me préoccupe c'est la suite oui des
choses vous n'êtes pas un seul qui est
préoccupé par ça parce que maintenant on
veut des actions concrètes c'est bien
j'ai beau la cc je pense que l'essentiel
de du message est passé mais il ya
peut-être une préoccupation que j'ai au
niveau du discours
ça dépend la traduction qu'on a fait
aussi parce que c'est parce que
j'attends aussi dense pour le mot excuse
puis dans les entrevues avec nos
délégations j'entends le mot regret
j'espère je me trompe elle veut pas
faire thématique la définition du mot
mais c'est quand même important à mon
avis si c'est des regrets la cch on
pourrait penser à autre chose mais si
jamais ça se concrétise
il va venir au canada faire les excuses
officielles
devant les familles affectées mais ce
qui me rend encore un peu triste c'est
que ça a pris tellement d'années il ya
des des aînés qui ont accompagné d'un
aux représentations qui ne sont plus de
ce monde ont tellement cru à ce que les
espèces viennent de l'église catholique
encore lola est ce que les excuses et
qu'on entend actuellement 20 ans du pape
jean du pape ou au nom de l'église
catholique
saucisses et c'est comme un peu
la communion sans moi
quand je vous dis le moi je veux aller
entendre des excuses officielles devant
des familles occasion j'espère qu'en qui
viendra dans la région du québec en tout
cas c'est ce que plusieurs souhaitent à
qu'il aille bien sûr dans l'ouest entre
autres à kamloops évidemment dans les
prairies et probablement aussi au québec
c'est trop tôt pour le dire mais
certains disent que cette visite va
arriver aussi tôt que le mois de juillet
là pour la fête de sainte-anne dites-moi
bon je vous ai entendu cette semaine
aussi vous l'avais répété encore
monsieur piétacho évidemment il ya les
mots et les excuses et à la suite on
parle entre autres d'avoir accès à ses
archives à ces documents pour savoir ce
qui est arrivé aux enfants est ce que
c'est ce que vous souhaitez aussi
un définissiez massif et c'est pas la
première fois qu'on demande c'est parce
que le monde oublie qu'on a fait
on a émis nos professions depuis
plusieurs années à travers des rapports
de commission
allait tout ce qu'on tout ce qu'on a dit
au sujet des enfants lors comme je vous
dis les aînés l'ont dit mais personne à
écouter mais ç'a pris des découvertes
moi je reste toujours sur le chiffre
symbolique de 2 5 15 enfants mélenchon
est rendu pour lundi mais le mesa pris
un événement qu'on savait des gens nous
qu'on a essayé de vous informer et
aujourd'hui je pense que un temps là le
pape aurait pu mettre un peu plus de
faux que sur les enfants retrouvés dans
deux sépultures
inconnu puis non définitivement mois
l'accès aux archives est important pour
qu'on nous a refusé
d'accéder à ses archives puis à d'autres
actions si les actions concrètes c'est
ce que j'ai dit les paroles non moi je
peut prononcer des paroles mais si
j'agis par conséquent ce que j'ai dit ça
va être difficile exemple qu'est ce
qu'on fait pour ceux celles qui ont
commis les crimes ce et des crimes qui
ont été commis un vin nos familles ceux
qui ont fréquenté
les enfants qui ont fréquenté les
pensionnats les enfants qu'ils ne sont
jamais retourner dans leur famille c'est
ce qui reste encore un bon moment c'est
par là que les télés la suite albanais
postés tous ces criminels il va falloir
utiliser les vrais murs et sessegnon des
sur le chemin du pardon mais
aussi la vérité comme ça devrait dit ne
se dit pas assez c'est ça aussi je pense
est important de le rappeler l'homme en
a tellement eu de pardon de des scrutins
passés mais les actions ne sont jamais
pareils
définitivement la savoie il faut qu'on
tienne compte de cela il faut qu'on soit
vigilant
je pense que le fait qu'ils viennent au
canada ben c'est déjà un peu comme on
dit mais on a tellement fait des potes
ne pas d'apporter puis l'élément
suspense est important aussi qu'il
faudra considérer ces éléments confiance
même à l'intérieur de nos premières
nations là on a tellement non c'est
d'actions qui ne sont jamais venus oui
il ya eu la période compensatoire mais
sauf que les cicatrices en vérité ces
quatre
island en vient donc le mot action je
pense que cette visite là ce que je
ressens lorsque vous le dites c'est que
ça pourrait être le moment pour entamer
justement ces actions là comment vous
voyez
comment on peut rebâtir l'arrêt à cela
la relation justement entre les
premières nations les peuples
autochtones et l'église catholique ici
au canada
j'appris j'appuie des décennies de
destruction au niveau spirituel au
niveau culturel uni
émotionnel
que rebâtir du jour au lendemain tout ce
qu'on a perdu depuis qu'on a comme
oublier la nouvelle génération souvent
l'histoire là elle est passée raconté à
mon avis la sécu oui à l'église
catholique mais on avait nos façons de
faire au niveau la spiritualité là la
vraie définition du spirituel ses
saucisses et ça amène un débat et je
pense que pour rebâtir ça prend la
confiance apprend
les jeunes d'aujourd'hui
moi j'étais jeune lorsque je suis allé
au personnel je savais même pas où
j'allais mais tout ça si on parle
beaucoup d'intergénérationnel puis je
poids sortie
non je pense qu'on a un travail je
n'aime pas le mot le mouv travail
l'homme est énorme le ballon sur
un long reportage à faire encore puis
définitivement dans ce portage l as
encore plusieurs embûches défaut falloir
affronter mais pour demain on peut
accueillir cette journée du 1er avril
comme deux buts 2 mais je sais pas où on
va se diriger mais peut-être pas falloir
l'emprunter meco falloir que le dialogue
se fait cela dans les deux dans les deux
sens parce que là un monologue qui dit
que m'excuser
à ccc on va prendre notre moulin est un
réel j'ai dit arrêt disco un réel
dialogue réel partenariat lopy la
réconciliation on est encore à des
kilomètres avant de convenir de dire là
mais je pense que encore une fois
j'aimerais ça
remercier nos délégations qui ont ré
expliquer leur douloureux séjour aussi
dans les pensionnats c'est surhumain
chevelu ventes là ils l'ont exprimé on
est comme un peu
d éléments qui peuvent maintenant
transmettre parce que les enfants aient
les 10000 enfin là c'est quand même des
enfants et des familles auraient aimé le
revoir et on parle comme nous
actuellement alors on a des éléments qui
fait que
le système continue chez poursuit la
colonisation elle est pas terminée là on
est en discussion depuis 40 ans je dis
sujet des affirmations de de se prendre
en mains de se décider pour épargne à
bien comme beaucoup beaucoup de de
chemin à faire mais la route est
commencé et elle sera longue jean
charles piétacho merci beaucoup
jamais greenpeace chine
et ses excuses du pape aux peuples
autochtones du canada ont eu un écho à
ottawa voici ce qu'a déclaré le premier
ministre justin trudeau le pape françois
a présenté ses excuses pour le rôle de
l'église dans les abus qui ont eu lieu
dans les pensionnats autochtones
c'est une étape importante
notre gouvernement va continuer de
soutenir les communautés autochtones à
travers le pays avec les ressources
nécessaires pour poursuivre les
recherches et tombes anonymes dévoilé là
vérité et continuer à guérir
on attend donc cette conférence de
presse officielle qui se passe à rome
mais vous revoyez mes invités qui sont
restés là merci beaucoup et zabelle
picard alain pronkin isabelle je
voudrais vous entendre on vient
d'entendre de supputations évidemment
beaucoup beaucoup de choses dans cette
entrevue là entre autres
toute la question de la culture
de restaurer entre autres choses la
culture hier je pense que c'est walter
des trottoirs qui disait j'étais le
dernier à parler la langue après ça la
langue est là vraiment disparu comment
on peut restaurer si c'est pas tout mais
en partie cette nature là qui a été
assimilée finalement oui voilà parce que
en fait les impacts de ces pensionnats
là ils sont bien sûr individuels mais
aussi collectifs y sont communautaires
et la langue fait partie d'un des
éléments qu'on a perdu étant donné qu'on
devait adopter le français ou l'anglais
dans les pensionnats au canada et les
foyers fédéraux comment est ce qu'on
fait il va falloir beaucoup de temps je
pense que monsieur péter à jour le 10
mai il a fallu beaucoup de ressources
aussi pour assimiler ou tenté
d'assimiler les autochtones par les
pensionnats il va falloir les mêmes
ressources pour rebâtir les langues et
des cultures alors moi je parle de
ressources financières de ressources
humaines je crois quand je crois qu'on
doit donner un gros coup de barre le
dans cette dans cette façon de rebâtir
les choses pour les générations futures
à vous parler deux langues comment
est-ce qu'on s'y prend c'est pas simple
il ya des langues qui sont complètement
éteinte
lio des langues qui ont des lexiques qui
proviennent des jésuites de
dictionnaires ancien de chez terra donc
on peut partir de ça mais ça demande des
ressources évidemment pour faire tout ça
c'est pas simple et il ya des langues
qui sont à l'agonie donc on doit aller
tout de suite voir les derniers
locuteurs et trouver des actions
concrètes qui vont faire en sorte que
cette langue l'oeuvre donc continuer
finalement d'être parlée dans les
communautés et vous savez à travers la
langue c'est pas seulement une langue
c'est pas seulement de la sémantique et
des mots mais c'est toute l'histoire du
territoire c'est toute la vision du
monde aussi donc elle est très
importante
disons cette réappropriation en
linguistique des langues autochtones au
canada sa prochaine c'est une tâche qui
attend l'église canadienne oui et ce qui
est important c'est que les nations
unies vient de déclarer la décade des
lampes des premières nations donc à
partir de 20 22 jusqu'à 20 32 ans va
mettre le focus sur la question des
langues autochtones et il ya eu une
demande spécifique à l'église catholique
de participer de deux façons
économiquement et par des ressources
jumelles à cette entreprise là qui est
déclarée par les nations unies donc ça
c'est très important
la deuxième chose et il va falloir que
dans un no man u elle décolle au niveau
de l'histoire on a cinq cette partie de
l'histoire canadienne est tout
simplement j'ai dit les gens à aller
faire un tour au musée douanes de qui ou
la baule et rizzoli voir c'est quoi un
village qui devient gérontologique parce
qu'on parle des enfants qui ont été
victimes d'abus physiques de biche
sexuelle dans ces pensionnats là mais on
oublie aussi des parents dans ces
villages eux qui ont vu un village sans
enfant imaginez une ville du québec ou
du canada aujourd'hui on dit à tous les
enfants on s'envoie avec vous comment
réagissent les parents quand les paroles
espère toujours le menu pour leurs
enfants ils doivent le mieux c'est il
revient jamais mais exclut la séparation
est cruelle pour ces parents là pour ses
enfants d'autres villages vides et ça
c'est important que j'invite les gens
les faire un don ou un dock et d'abuser
on explique cette cet événement-là sets
7-6 6-4 islah qui fait partie de notre
société la belle vous serez heureuse
dans cette suggestion de monsieur propre
qui naturellement dans l'outback et
monsieur piétacho semblait dire ben oui
on marche dans ce chemin de la
réconciliation mais la jota va être
drôlement longue elle a été longue elle
va l'être encore est-ce que ce que vous
êtes un peu plus ce que vous avez un peu
plus d'espoir que lui que les choses
aillent plus vite à partir de cet
événement important de ce matin madame
picard
oui j'ai beaucoup aimé la nuance que
monsieur pietà choix apporter du fait
qu'on doit aller au delà des excuses
pour moi ça c'est un passage obligé
c'est absolument important les mots ça
reste des millions doit mettre des
actions concrètes de l'avant et donc est
ce que je suis plus optimiste
effectivement je pense que d'abord
entendu le pape avec les mots qu'il
utilise est on le rappelle il a parlé de
honte il parler d'humiliation
d'indignation je pense qu'il a compris
il a il a entendu et pour moi ça fait
partie de tout un processus de guérison
je pense que certaines personnes des
survivants avait besoin qu'on
reconnaisse les torts qui ont été causés
je pense que ce matin le pape le fait il
va le faire mieux probablement quand il
sera directement au canada
oui donc je pense que c'est le début de
quelque chose mais vous savez je reste
quand même un petit peu cynique en ce
sens que je comprends le super tâches ou
en a eu plusieurs commissions à la
commission vérité et réconciliation
la commission vient y eu plusieurs
commissions en lien royal d' enquête au
niveau des autochtones et il ya eu peu
d'appel à l'action qui ont été suivis ou
peu de recommandations qui ont été
suivis jusqu'à maintenant vous parler
des langues tout à l'heure j'aimerais
beaucoup voir la reconnaissance des
langues autochtones au niveau du
gouvernement fédéral ce secteur une des
actions concrètes sa peau ça pas de lien
directement avec l'église mais
évidemment c'est dans toutes ses
conséquences là on a vu en lien avec
avec les pensionnaires et des foyers
fédéraux donc oui je suis encore
optimiste mais il faut des actions
rapides et concrètes est ce que monsieur
procaine le gouvernement du canada va
aussi mettre l épaule à la roue on
entendait zabel qui disait on voudrait
de reconnaissance et des langues
autochtones ici au canada dont la visite
sera sans doute orchestré vous l'évoquez
tout à l'heure avec le gouvernement quel
sera son rôle
le gouvernement a déjà mis ses archives
et là on a appris qu'il était acceptée
même normal que les enfants soient
victimes d'abus physiques dans les
passionnés c'est déjà reconnu on l'a
déjà dans les archives canadienne la une
que va faire le gouvernement fédéral il
ya encore des pas importants parce qu'on
sait aussi que le gouvernement fédéral
avait décidé d'un coup on va transférer
à vous dire la dpj la juridiction sur
les abeilles beaucoup d'enfants
autochtones qui ont été pris dans leur
foyer et qui ont été tout simplement
envoyé un peu partout aux états unis en
europe on a des enfants des premières
nations qui sont trouvés ailleurs on a
aussi toute la question du territoire la
question du territoire mais ne pas
déterrer les mêmes du côté des métis on
a écouté on sait que nos pères ont
pratiquement été donnée à différentes
entreprises et pour faire et des prêts
ont participé à ces cette expropriation
déguisée du territoire et de toute la
question du territoire qu'est ce qu'on
fait avec des territoires qui ont été
cédés en guise mais sans droit et ça
c'est important de le gouvernement
fédéral va voir un autre est mort dit
elle a joué des doit intervenir c'est en
effet tout un tas une tâche très vert
cela qui est devant devant ce processus
de guérison de réconciliation isabelle
picard alain pronkin nous vous restez là
je vais me tourner vers la journaliste
gabriel paul qui est d'espèces
autochtones et si à radio canada parce
qu'on l'a évoqué tout à l'heure bonjour
gabriel
et à des réactions au pays à ses excuses
du pape
ça faisait très longtemps qu'elle était
attendu ses excuses donc il est beaucoup
de membres des communautés autochtones
au pays qui attendait ce jour avec
impatience mais déjà le consensus et que
c'est une première étape
vers une réconciliation donc la
reconnaissance de l'église des subissent
qui sont survenus dans les pensionnats
c'est une première étape vers des
actions plus concrètes
par exemple pour michèle audette qui est
sénatrice et qui a été commissaire de
l'enquêté nationale sur les femmes et
les filles autochtones disparues et
assassinées mais c'est vraiment une
occasion de pouvoir réécrire l'histoire
je vous invite à l'écouter
on peut maintenant assurer que nos
leaders vont parler avec ces gens et
revoir et redéfinir quelle a été la
fameuse terra nullius je suis arrivé en
premier donc que ça m'appartient où il
ya juste moi qui habite ce grand
territoire et bien sûr je nous souhaite
collectivement avoir accès aux archives
même si les excuses du pape aujourd'hui
sont une bonne nouvelle
certains sont un peu déçus de la manière
dont le pape a présenté ses excuses
notamment certains auraient voulu que le
pas mentionne toutes les vies qui ont
été perdues dans les pensionnats c'est
le cas notamment de richard kistabish
qui a été chef de la première nation
abitibiwinni de pikogan et qui est un
solvant lui-même dépassionnant on peut
l'écouter à s'auto
la formulation béa la phrase des excuses
qui me qui me déçoit beaucoup
parce que il a oublié quand même
certains détails est importante donc la
découverte d'ailleurs des corps
d'enfants à kamloops
y avait bien sûr beaucoup de demandes de
la part des différentes délégations
gabriel qui sont sur place
et certaines de ces demandes n'ont pas
été mentionnés par le pape oui tout à
fait notamment toute la question des
artefacts qui sont pris en ce moment au
26 exécutions exactement parce qu'il ya
plusieurs objets qui viennent de
communautés autochtones au canada qui
sont au vasco et ses peaux claires
comment le vatican s'est procuré ces
objets là ils ont été accueillis d'une
manière plutôt des blues donc les
autochtones souhaitait pouvoir rapatrier
ces objets là chez eux puis cette
semaine quand ils ont visité ce musée
certains étaient très déçus de voir la
façon dont ces objets étaient entreposés
entretenu parce que c'est souvent des
objets très important spirituellement
traditionnellement donc c'est une des
choses que le pape n'a pas mentionné
mais il reste à voir si si quand même
des démarches ont été entreprises par
les communautés afin de récupérer ces
objets absolument merci google réel ça
me fait plaisir
et je vais bondir là dessus pour me
tourner vers isabelle picard et alain
prokin mais abaisse voudrais vous
entendre parce que c'est vrai que j'ai
lu entre autres le papier de ma collègue
marie laure josselin qui parlait de
cette visite la au musée du vatican qui
disaient certains membres des
délégations ont eu comme un goût amer à
voir sa des chances qu'on ne savait pas
qui était dans ce musée du vatican entre
autres un canot dont je me souviens de
la photo
effectivement quelle est l'importance de
ces artefacts l'est et surtout quelle
est l'importance de les ramener
peut-être dans les communautés
web et l'importance et les ailes et
haute qu'on parle d'action de
réconciliation je pense que ça peut en
être une qui peut être très concrètes on
parle d'un canot c'est un canot ce sacre
est un donc il ya des objets parmi ces
objets là qu'on n'avait jamais vu en
tant que métis inuits ou membres des
premières nations et qui ont une
importance disons extrême au niveau de
la spiritualité on parle de wham paume
aussi qui provient de cannes s attaquer
on sait que les vins pommes étaient des
documents donc un support matériel qui
souvent scellait une vision des choses
ou une entente ou donc ce sont des
témoins importants de l'histoire et la
question et les bonnes que pose et
gabriel on sait pas si ils ont été
données ou s'ils nous ont peu été pris
et il y avait un grand malaise je pense
une tristesse à la vue de tous ces
objets là qu'ils se sont rendus au
vatican on ne sait comment et donc du
lieu tout en muséologie de façon
générale de toute façon partout en
europe on est en train dé même en
amérique on est en train de repenser à
un retour des artefacts autochtone qui
pour la plupart ont été pris donc ôter
et donc je pense que là on a une
occasion claire d'une action concrète
qui va faire en sorte qu'on va procéder
au niveau de la guérison et de de tout
ce cheminement le conduite en train de
faire avec avec l'église est-ce que vous
pensez que la demande va être fait pour
qu'on peut se récupérer ces objets la
sarthe et facteurs
j'en suis certaine j'en suis certaine si
sap a déjà été exprimé verbalement il ya
quelque chose qui va suivre à cet effet
là je vous parlais de war room de cannes
s attaquer moi j'ai vécu là pendant
longtemps et on était très surpris et on
ne le dit pas il faut il faut en
connaître davantage il faut savoir d'où
il vient comment il s'est rendu là et on
aimerait leurs avoirs chine absolument
as éperon keane j'aimerais qu'on parle
un peu de de l'aspect criminel entre
guillemets parce que monsieur tâche on
le disait évidemment il ya des gens de
l'église qui ont déjà été jugé il ya eu
des compensations financières qui ont
été versés certaines autres qui sont
encore attendus par par les victimes de
ces pensionnats pour autochtones quelle
sera la suite dans ces dossiers
judiciariser laisse qu'on va punir
ceux qui sont qui sont responsables de
ces crimes l'oeil qui sont encore en vie
oui ça c'est la demande concernant le
prêtre ivoire qui est actionnaire
carrément souvent france on peut pas
l'extrader sans doute pour des questions
légales dont je connais pas les détails
mais les premières nations aux demandes
et les inuit plus particulièrement
demandé au pape de dire à ce prêtre de
revenir au canada pour subir son procès
mais ça soulève une autre question tout
un pan de mur qui est celui de combien
de prêtres combien de religieux ont été
accusés canonique manoj parle pas de
justice criminelle ou la justice civile
au canada mais au vatican parce qu'on
sait comme le pet brière à montréal ont
été jugés helvétique indique que vous
n'êtes plus prêtre on essaie pour le
cardinal mais carrick mais ce que
d'autres prêtes on n'a aucune idée de
combien de prêtres ont été accusés
d'agressions sur des enfants en rapport
avec les pensionnats est-ce que des doux
aussi ou vatican à ce sujet doit s que
des dossiers à la congrégation pour la
doctrine de la foi et c'est une des
grandes questions est ce que la
congrégation de la doctrine de la foi a
dit oui on accepte de participer au
processus eh oui voici la liste des
prêtres de religieux de religieuses qui
ont participé à aux agressions physiques
sur les enfants sont n'ignore est-ce que
des doux aussi à ce sujet là chez les
évêques au canada on ignore actuellement
mais ça c'est une question importante
peut-être l'église votre valeur on peut
pas aux vrais seydoux au sida parce que
des témoins parce qu'ici parce que ça
mais c'est une question qui se pose une
question que des premières nations les
métis et les inuits ont droit d'avoir
une réponse sur ces questions c'est
primordial de savoir qu'un uniquement
qu'est ce qu'on a fait ou est ce qu'on a
fait quelque chose parce que n'oublions
jamais le pape déjà déclaré que la
tradition dans l'église jusqu'à très
récemment s'est déplacé un prêtre
pédophile est ce qu on a fait la même
chose pour des prêts de tosic élise
luigi chinetti chez les premières
nations ça fait beaucoup d'actions qui
sont demandées ils avaient appuyé quand
on devrait commencer par lesquels par
laquelle
l'accès aux archives pour moi le sait le
départ on a dit tout à l'heure les
oblats ont quand même ouvert leurs
archives générales mais à ce qu'on m'a
dit ils n'ont pas ouvert leurs archives
individuel donc des prêtes et du
personnel des pensionnats je sais pas si
je me trompe mais c'est ce que j'ai lu
et donc pour moi ça fait toute une
différence donc on veut aller beaucoup
plus loin que dans le général on veut
voir comment les gens pensaient ce
qu'ils ont fait et justement est ce qu a
eu des actions en justice et ce qui est
bon est chez terrain on veut voir celui
des réprimandes comment est-ce qu'on
fonctionner je pense que vous savez le
chemin de la guérison c'est un peu comme
un grand casse-tête et là il nous manque
des pièces du casse-tête et ses archives
leur vont nous permettre de répondre à
certains questionnements et de pouvoir
cheminer donc dans toute cette cette
guérison dont je parle dans toute cette
réconciliation aussi pour moi ça c'est
la première étape de bien connaître les
faits et de savoir ce qui s'est
réellement passé nous on le sait par la
tradition orale mais de l'autre côté
comme est ce qu'on voyait les choses
comment cet effet est ce qu'il y avait
comment est-ce qu'on punisse est bon
chez terra je pense que ça fait partie
de tout ce chemin de guérison se prend
ken l'enseignant poissons voire beaucoup
de travail à faire et ce au canada où il
y avait beaucoup qui est effectivement
coms et isabelle deux types d'archivés
les archives comme on dit généralement
et toutes les archives privées ou les
archives secrètes des archis prix vous
secret tu sais quoi c'est un évêque qui
a ses propres archives personnelles et
la grande question d'un seul homme est
ce que c'est le aussi vont être ouverts
pour poser directement la question à mon
j'ai l'impression que beaucoup de trafic
devant lui c est ce qu on veut dire oui
on ouvre les archives privées au
personnel des différentes des règles qui
étaient au canada c'était au club
pongiste les archives sacramentelle ou
des archives moi je qualifie de général
encore beaucoup de questions sans
réponse je dois remercier les gens qui
nous écoutent ce récit télé parce qu'on
était sur les deux chaînes depuis ce
matin la programmation qui se poursuit
par contre on va poursuivre bien sûr sur
un sirh dei parce que le point de presse
à rome
comment cela au cours des ces commencer
on va aller faire un tour
dans des oblats du conseil des évêques
et nous avons rencontré sa sainteté au
cours de nos conversations
que nous sommes ici pour articuler aussi
clairement que possible
ce qui reste à faire de la part de
l'église catholique afin d'assurer la
vérité la justice la guérison et la
réconciliation parce qu'il du rôle de
l'église catholique dans
ce qui s'est passé au niveau du système
de pensionnat au canada plusieurs i know
it sont allées étaient dans ce système
des pensionnats et plusieurs
ont connu la bu
il y a eu des traumatismes du
traumatisme qui perdure dans nos
communautés notamment au niveau inter
générationnelle nous avons fait face à
ces situations avec d'autres
institutions telles que l'église
anglicane nous avons travaillé avec le
gouvernement fédéral et plusieurs de ses
ministères mais cette semaine nous
sommes ici pour être en conversation
travailler avec l'église catholique je
suis très reconnaissant
de la manière dont le conseil des
évêques canadiens à collaborer avec nous
afin d'assurer un accès aux espaces
donc nous avons besoin
pour
accomplir
les actions nécessaires envers la
justice et la guérison ici à rome nous
avons rencontré le pape ce lundi pour ce
qui est de la délégation et nous et et
nous l'avons rencontré également
aujourd'hui avec les autres délégations
les excuses qui ont été faites
et il était temps qu'elles aient lieu
et s'est aussi des excuses
envers lesquels les
survivant individuelle et communautaire
ressenti en fait ils ressenti très
différents selon les personnes et les
communautés en tant qu'institution nous
avons demandé ses excuses de manière
formelle
et par plusieurs appels à l'action
en préparation également pour cette
rencontre particulière cette semaine
donc c'était une position claire et nous
recherchions unique des excuses papa lé
là est une reconnaissance du système des
pensionnats dans ce pays au canada donc
il ya une pièce importante du poteau qui
tombent en place actuellement et nous
avons écouté
un discours venant du coeur du pape du
pape françois avec qui a été dit qui a
été exprimé avec beaucoup de soin j'ai
été touché par
sa peine et la manière dont il a
condamné les actions de l'église de
différentes manières il y encore
beaucoup de choses à faire et donc des
excuses font partie peu portrait
beaucoup plus globale où nous étions
également ici cette semaine
afin de
mettre en lumière un haut blanc
catholique français nous voudrions qu'il
soit envoyé au canada pour faire face à
des condamnations d'abus sexuels nous
avons travaillé avec l'église catholique
qui ils ont exprimé la volonté de
travailler avec nous pour que justice se
fasse dans ce cas particulier disons le
ce n'est pas le seul cas que nous
voudrions voir résolus il y en a
d'autres et il y a des gens qui
souffrent actuellement qui ont besoin
que justice soit rendue et le travail
que nous faisons en temps qui nous est
première nation
doit se faire en collaboration avec
l'église catholique si nous voulons
faire en sorte que cette semaine soit un
point tournant dans la rue a sion entre
nous et l'église catholique alors
j'accueille maintenant vos questions
et je vous remercie de me céder la
parole aujourd'hui
c'est bonjour à tous je suis catholique
à rennes mais je suis président du
conseil national métis je ne suis pas
ici pour me représenter ou mes propres
histoires je ne suis pas rome
pour une représentation individuelle
mais plutôt pour livrer un message au
nom de nos citoyens à la maison les
citoyens métisse et c'est ce que nous
avons fait cette semaine et je voudrais
d'abord exprimer ma grande
reconnaissance pour ce qui est de la
délégation médecis qui a porté cette
responsabilité afin de livrer ses
messages au saint-père lundi notamment
dans l'espoir que nous serions en mesure
en tant que peuple métis nous avons
cherché à être reconnue depuis longtemps
nous nous sommes inclus dans la
constitution depuis
1982 mais jusqu'en 2016 nous avons
continué à lutter pour être reconnu et
le voici si aujourd'hui on nous entend
on nous entend à l'échelle
internationale et on sent qu'on nous
écoute et je suis empli de
reconnaissance pour cela et merci à tous
d'être ici aujourd'hui est de nous
écouter lundi nous avons parlé au pape
françois et nous l'avons invité qui va
parcourir un chemin de vérité de
guérison de réconciliation de justice et
tous les messages que nous avons
transmis au pape prend soin
sur le résultat des heures passées avec
le survivant nous survivants
intergénérationnel pour que nous
puissions représenter la diversité de la
nation matt métier c'est la diversité de
leurs perspectives et la déclaration du
pape francis ce matin reflète que nous
avons été entendus il a reflété la
manière dont nous sommes
l'interconnexion humaine les relations
humaines partagées je l'entends dans son
message et serait très significatif pour
nous les excuses que nous avons reçu ce
matin son historique est tellement
significative pour tellement de
personnes cela ouvre la porte pour nous
de continuer à parcourir ce chemin de la
guérison et cela ouvre la porte aussi
pour que nous continuons à lutter pour
que actions se fasse et le pape françois
l'heure inconnu lorsqu'il dit que tout
processus
efficace de guérison appel à l'action et
c'est vrai aussi que toutes les
délégations le 10 des excuses 7ème étape
certes importante mais le travail
continue et il y à beaucoup d'action à
prendre
c'est un grand honneur pour moi d'être
ici aujourd'hui est d'avoir été en
compagnie de nos amis ou nos survivants
lors de cette rencontre avec le pape
parce que c'est pour ces personnes pour
nous survivants pour noé mais
que nous sommes ici aujourd'hui et je
n'ai pas les mots pour exprimer ce que
les gens qui sont maintenant décédé
aurait ressenti s'il avait pu être ici
aujourd'hui et nous ramènerons ces
messages chez nous et nous attendrons
les baisers de table et il est
envisageable que son message soit
semblable sinon encore plus fort
lorsqu'ils visiteront nos communautés il
a rencontré craint personne cette
semaine et il a été tellement touché et
il s'est excusé alors imaginez ce qu'ils
allaient ce qu'ils pourraient ressentir
lorsqu'il va voir nos communautés
rencontrer nos gens possiblement visiter
certains des pensionnats qui existent
encore
les édifices qui existent encore alors
notre espoir aussi c'est que le pape
françois rendre visite à nos sites les
plus spirituelles donc nous avons
beaucoup de travail au sein de la nation
métisse pour faire en sorte que nos
histoires soient encore entendus nos
survie un
endroit la justice plusieurs d'entre eux
n'ont pas été reconnues par les ententes
par rapport au système des pensionnats
et donc ce jour est très significatif
pour ceux qui ont été mis à l'écart du
processus et nous continuerons de lutter
en tant que nation métisse pour que nos
survivants soient reconnus puisque il
mérite d'être connu
alors j'ai hâte de voir comment nous
allons avancer vers l'avenir ça a été le
message de toute la semaine on lui parle
d' excuses certes mais nous avons aussi
été très clair à savoir qu'il ya encore
beaucoup d'étapes à suivre et nous
savons que nous allons avancer et
qu'ensemble nous sommes forts je pense
que ce fut un message très clair cette
semaine c'est qu'en collaborant ensemble
on peut faire
l'impossible est un
travaillant avec nos frères et soeurs
des nations inoue des premières nations
et l'unité de nos peuples autochtones et
a été très clair cette semaine et j'ai
beaucoup de fierté à marcher ensemble
avec mes frères et soeurs autochtone et
de continuer à faire ce travail
merci
[Applaudissements]
massé mike brodeur
merci mes frères mes soeurs
today aujourd'hui
est une journée que nous attendions
depuis longtemps oui et quand je dis
nous notre famille
toutes ces personnes au canada
et c'est une journée qui sera très
certainement historique
sa sainteté le pape françois
est à la tête de l'église catholique
à exprimer des excuses
qui tardait
pour ce qui est du rôle de l'église
notamment au niveau du système des
pensionnats
et je suis convaincu
que c'est une journée empli d'émotion
aujourd'hui
nous échapper nous acceptons ses excuses
comme geste de bonne foi
il reconnaît qu'il viendra sur nos
terres qu'il rendra visite à nos
familles afin d'exprimer des excuses
formelles à tous les membres de notre
famille
c'est une journée pour nous
qui est très spécial enfin enfin nous
pourrons
commencer
fermer
ses souffrances
entrevoir une fin à celles-ci et ce
geste positif comme je les dis plutôt ce
n'est pas sans rappeler la chasse nous
avons identifié des traces de pas toutes
fraîches
cela dit le travail reste à faire
il faut suivre les traces que nous avons
identifiés ces traces fraîches et donc
nous avons
deux chemins ou une pression
extraordinaire
un mode de vie extraordinaire nous
savons
que ce mode de vie nous a menés jusqu'à
aujourd'hui
nous n'avons jamais abandonné nos
enseignements nous n'avons pas donné nos
langues nous n'avons pas abandonné notre
culture jamais et nous n'avons pas
abandonné le système de gouvernance
ainsi
vont les choses pourront changer
alors que nous allons vers l'avenir
parce que ce que j'aimerais partager
avec vous parmi d'autres
et c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
sommes ici en tant que messager ici à
rome nous allons rentrer chez nous afin
de partager ce que nous avons entendu
ici ce que nous avons vécu
[Musique]
étudiants dans le système des
pensionnats canadiens
nous connaissons la destruction et les
traumatismes
qui résulte de cet effort concerté le
génocide
l'héritage est l'histoire du système de
pensionnat
sont toujours en vie et c'est vrai pour
nos grands parents leurs enfants et
leurs petits enfants
la colonisation
une fait preuve d'un effort concerté par
le biais de leurs lois et leurs
politiques en collaboration avec les
organisations religieuses afin
d'implanter un plein envers les peuples
autochtones et nous allons continuer
à le dire
et à faire appel à du soutien de l'aide
notamment au gouvernement fédéral
afin de mettre fin
à ce génocide de amorcée depuis
longtemps les bus
amorcée depuis longtemps
voir
cette idée de suicide collectif
il ya aussi des lois colonisatrice qui
cherchait à arriver à des fins par
rapport aux peuples autochtones et donc
il ya encore énormément de travail à
accomplir et je
voudrais aborder cette idée de gym aussi
c'est le résultat
des
deux d'avoir demandé un droit à la
documentation une revendication au droit
à la domination
c'est une vérité une autre chose que
j'aimerais dire c'est qu'il y a des
manières de faire des deux ministres et
ce processus est donc
ce sont des questions qu'il faut aborder
continuer à aborder il y a encore
beaucoup de travail à faire je voudrais
aussi dire
que
toutes les
souffrances exprimées par nos nations
ressentie par nos nations face à la
découverte des sépultures c'est une
tragédie inimaginable
et lorsque cela était entendu il y avait
énormément
d'émotion à travers le monde lorsque aux
mamans étaient récemment témoins
et
évidemment il y a énormément d'appuis à
l'échelle mondiale qui vient vers nous
et nous remercions nos amis et nos
alliés de parler la vérité alors que
nous revivons là l'autre et nous vous
nous appelons à votre support à votre
soutien alors que nous guérison
guérissant et reconstruisant nos
familles
les indices d'or en effet c'est une
c'est un pas historique
pour le saint père et nous cherchons à
entendre ces mots d' excuses sur nos
terres et dans nos communautés
rien n'aurait été possible sans la
collaboration
et la force
de nos familles de nos gens de notre
leadership de nos organisations
nous aurons aussi
vous pouvez la voir aujourd'hui
avec mes frères et soeurs
nous
collaborons et nous réfléchissons à
comment nous continuerons de collaborer
et encore une fois nous avons eu
plusieurs conversations
pour ce qui est du travail à faire qui a
besoin d'être fait et nous devons
continuer à collaborer parce que nous
sommes membres d'une famille commune
nous acceptons ses excuses en tant que
geste de bonne foi et j'aimerais
terminer en disant que
oui au
fût une véritable bénédiction pour nous
en tant que délégation et je suis
certain que certains se sont demandés
pourquoi moi et donc ce fut très
particulier d'avoir nous aimer avec nous
aujourd'hui d'écouter leur partage est
une des choses qu'ils ont dit c'est
qu'il y a des pouvoirs plus grands que
nous
l'énergie de nos ancêtres notamment qui
a travaillé à leur manière afin
d'aligner les choses pour qu'elles
soient alignées comme elle devrait
l'être
donc aujourd'hui
avec tous
ce soutien
pour ceux d'entre vous qui font ce genre
de travail nous aimerions exprimer notre
reconnaissance et aujourd'hui ce qu'on
voit c'est le pouvoir de ces énergies de
ses forces qui ont fait en sorte que la
journée d'aujourd'hui a pu avoir lieu et
donc j'exprime ma vive reconnaissance
pour
tout ce qui a pu être fait à leur
manière pour que les énergies
contribuer
tout le travail qui se fait et pour que
ce que les familles hinault de notre
grande famille a exprimé a pu être
exprimée est entendu et nous
représentons aussi nos enfants et nos
petits enfants qui nous on est également
avec énergie par le biais de l'énergie
nous ont donné de la force et nous ont
inspirés dans ce travail ce qui était
reviennent aux enfants par le passé est
vraiment tragique et c'est quelque chose
que nous avons eu à endurer
malgré tout nous n'avons jamais
abandonné donc
je remercie tout le leadership du passé
tous mes parents tous nos grands parents
tous nos aînés qui continue de manière
cohérente à partager avec nous et on
continue nos inspiré merci
sauf un caillou match personnes obèses
alors merci beaucoup président aux
belles prises macarons et le chef emploi
au vin ce soir le pape françoise
exprimant non non un autre nom pour
l'église et pour les éveils que nous
devons avoir un esprit d'accompagnement
et j'utilise le mot accompagnement parce
que j'espère que cette semaine a été
l'expression de notre désir
d'accompagner les autres et surtout
notre communauté autochtone qui l'ont le
ont vécu les faits les tragédies du
système des pensionnats canadiens et
aussi c'est vrai pour les communautés
qui continuent de vivre les conséquences
de ce système ou plusieurs disques sept
systèmes et historique sinon divine
c'est un mot que j'ai entendu souvent
cette semaine mais lorsque nous
traversons de telles expériences et nous
savons parfois que cela va au-delà de
nos capacités humaines
c'est à dire qu'il ya une reconnaissance
de la présence de dieu et du créateur
cela dit je pense qu'il ya énormément de
reconnaissance de la part de l'église
catholique du canada envers le pape
françois ce fut un grand privilège pour
nous évêques d'être présent cette
semaine
les rencontres individuelles avec les
métis les premières nations et les inuit
ce parcours n'aurait pu être possible
sans le soutien
des les deux ici présents
cette marche que nous faisons ensemble
et qui ont abouti à cette semaine a
commencé il ya peut-être deux ou trois
ans déjà est ce que nous savions où nous
allions
autre que de partager un désir de
rencontrer le pape ou de lui permettre
d'écouter directement les voix de ceux
qui ont souffert
et lors de ces rencontres privées pour
nous qui ont le privilège d'être présent
nous avons vu un homme un père
dont le corps a été profondément touchée
par ces histoires
ses expériences vécues par les aînés qui
ont vécu le siam des personnes seules a
été exprimée par des gestes simples
c'est à dire de la part du saint père il
a touché les gens physiquement il les a
bénis
il aura ce qui leur a souhaité la
bienvenue en tant que symbole du système
des pensionnats et dans chacun de ses
gestes que nous avons vue j'espère que
les gens qu'ils ont reçus ont reconnu
également un esprit partagé par les
évêques du canada en ce sens qu'ils
voulaient que les histoires soient
entendues et qu'une réponse empli de
compassion soit reçue au
nom de l'église
c'est un jour lors duquel le pape
françois exprimé son désir de pardon de
dieu et qu'il a dit fond du coeur qu'il
était empli de regret qu'il s'excusait
et qu'il vous demander pardon
notamment au nom du g20 au canada
alors de recevoir le pardon de faire des
excuses comme vous l'avez entendu doit
être suivi par les actions à prendre et
en tant qu'eglise catholique et diocèse
nous
sommes ouverts à donner accès à nos
archives et les leaders autochtones
l'ont entendue cette semaine de la part
des oblats et aussi de la part du
secrétaire d'état j'espère que ces
rencontres auront on vous ont donné
confiance
et que vous avez entendu que l'église
continue de vouloir démontrer de manière
concrète son engagement envers ce chemin
de guerre ils ont de vérité et de
réconciliation et de justice
le pape françois
reconnaît le cri des pauvres
s'il a lui même choisi le nom françois
à l'exemple de saint françois qui était
amoureux de la mère terre amoureux de la
création
alors que j'écoutais ce qui s'exprimait
pendant les rencontres et alors que
j'écoutais le discours du pape françois
j'ai constaté qu'il reconnaît ce la
contribution des peuples autochtones
la contribution de la spiritualité de la
culture de la langue ce sont des cadeaux
que nous avons reçus des peuples
autochtones et le pape a aussi reconnu
la grande vérité exprimées par les
peuples autochtones c'est à dire qu'il
ne s'agit pas de penser seulement du
présent mais il faut reconnaître le
passé surtout une part le répéter les
aussi il faut réfléchir aux sept
générations qui nous suivent et ce sont
les enseignements c'est le cadeau de la
spiritualité autochtone c'est un cadeau
envers l'humanité et envers l'église
ce qui a été dit par plusieurs d'entre
ceux qui ont pu partager leur expérience
c'est à dire les délégués en fait je
pense
qu'ils ont peut-être est-ce le chemin
qu'on nous a demandé de tracer un chemin
que nous ne connaissions pas alors que
nous commencions le suivre mais un
chemin qui ce tracé que d'autres
suivront c'est aussi ce que le pape
reconnaît c'est son lycée son espoir que
les rencontres de la semaine
seront de nouveaux chemins qui pourront
être parcourus ensemble afin d'espérer
le courage la force et de mener à un
plus grand engagement au niveau local
etc c'est le désir l'église catholique
canadienne c'est à dire de cheminer sur
le chemin de la guérison de la vérité de
la justice au niveau local partout au
canada pour que les canadiens et les
catholiques puissent reconnaître le
passé mais aussi reconnaître les
tragédies qui continuent d'avoir lieu
aujourd'hui si nous continuons être
influencé par le colonialisme et les
forces qui le reflet et qui demeure
évidente encore aujourd'hui ces mots ont
été entendus ressenti et pour ceux qui
l'ont rencontré cette semaine on
reconnaît que c'est un homme qui cherche
la réconciliation et non nous a
certainement courage et nous les évêques
avec beaucoup d'humilité
avec l'humilité de la tradition nous
avons tous à marcher ensemble sur ce
chemin alors j'aimerais vous exprimer ma
reconnaissance pour tout le travail que
vous avez accompli pour toute
l'organisation
qui a fait en sorte que cette semaine
est devenu possible alors le succès et
le crédit vous revient
vous les peuples autochtones qui ont
marché à nos côtés cette semaine merci
jusqu'à peu plus fort impressionné alors
monseigneur poissons nous vous adressons
nous vous donnons également l'accès au
micro
c'est très bien on a compris moi je suis
très heureux je veux remercier nos
leaders qui sont ici avec nous et je
répète avec mon chien mcgrattan notre
désir de continuer cette route c'est une
étape importante que nous avons vécu
ensemble sont des rencontres historiques
et elles ne finissent pas cette semaine
elle se continue d'ailleurs le saint
père il a fait un petit peu allusion ce
matin il s'attend à venir nous voir un
jour alors merci beaucoup et poursuivons
la route
qui tue respect que je te remercie
une gestion frais journalistes s'il vous
plaît de
l'identifier votre organisation de
presse et préciser à qui vous adressez
votre question
ce soir en question je suis de cibler
ses news une question se pose au québec
mais si les dirigeants autochtones
voulait intervenir je voudrais aussi
licence pourquoi est-ce qu'il a fallu
aussi longtemps pour que le pape
présente ses excuses
on a fait ces demandes là il y a déjà
plusieurs années et pourquoi s'il a
fallu autant de temps et pourquoi ce
voyage était nécessaire pour que cette
présentation d'excusés se déroule
finalement
merci pour votre question
ben woodside et et certains diront qu'il
a fallu un certain temps depuis la
publication du rapport de la commission
de vérité réconciliation mais dans des
amis qui ont suivi la publication de ce
rapport il y a eu un
le dialogue nécessaire pour voir comment
comprendre et comment aider le saint
père nous sert ce qu'il a fait
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il était très
important en particulier
le fait d'organiser des rencontres
personnelles avec des survivants du
pensionnat mais aussi avec des aînés et
des jeunes
ce qu'il a pu dire
répondent pas l'expérience qui l'avait
fait lui même à travers ces rencontres
c'était important pour le saint père de
d'écouté
et ensuite d'exprimer de façon
authentique et que les émotions que 7e
rencontre a provoqué six essais je pense
dans ce contexte qu'il a formulé ses
excuses du fond du coeur après avoir
entendu les témoignages présentés cette
semaine oui c'est vrai qu'il a fallu
beaucoup de temps
mais
nous allons continuer de cheminer sur ce
chemin de la réconciliation et nous
espérons pouvoir construire sur ce but a
dit ce que les évêques du cameroun déjà
dit et nous allons essayer de produire
des signes concrets de cette
réconciliation et de se demande de
pardon simplement pour dire que ce teint
il me semble bon plus long - l'on
n'était pas perdu car dès le dépôt du
rapport à la commission
la conférence des évêques catholiques du
canada commencé à travailler notamment
avec 2 certes notre dame de la
guadeloupe donc avec des personnes des
communautés autochtones et nous
travailler ensemble à mieux se connaître
et à mieux connaître cette histoire qui
n'était pas très bien connue de
l'ensemble de la population du canada et
il me semble que nous l'avons dit et
répété
les ce que nous avons vécu ce matin
comme message de ses pairs ont encore eu
d'autant plus de valeur comme le disait
mon collègue que il est fait à partir
d'expériences partagées avec des
survivants des aînés étaient jeunes qui
sont venus le visiter c'était une étape
importante cette délégation ça n'aurait
pas pris tant de temps si nous n'avions
pas eu dans
l'organisation lévitation que c'est fait
d'elle-même l'aco vide parce que nous
avons quand même reporté la délégation à
deux reprises
je suis de globo news
ma question est pour les évêques
je comprends que vous même et la série
d'état du vatican vous êtes engagé à
appuyer la recherche des documents
reliés au pensionnat mais il ya d'autres
demandes il y a aussi une demande de
révocation de bulle papale qui remonte à
plusieurs siècles une demande aussi de
demande de pardon en sol canadien
ces choses là sont de très simple les
politiciens font cela régulièrement
le vatican est un état pourquoi est ce
qu'on ne peut être pas dire tout de
suite aujourd'hui qu'on va faire ces
choses là pourquoi
est ce que tout cela n'est pas aussi
simple que cela semblerait
[Musique]
vous impose d'abord une question à
propos de ce qui a été présenté dans le
cadre des rencontres privées cela
portait sur la doctrine de découverte et
le principe de terre à nu youth ce que
je voudrais dire c'est que la conférence
des évêques
du canada est d'accord pour dire que les
principes qui sous-tendent de cette
approche c'est quelque chose que nous
n'appuyons pas et en 2016 je vous fais
une lettre pastorale qui dénonçait ce
qu'on entendait par la doctrine de la
découverte nous avons expliqué pourquoi
la doctrine de la découverte a aussi des
conséquences dans d'autres et à d'autres
juridictions pour ce qui est du canada
il y a aussi
d'autres conférences épiscopales qui ont
fait la même chose c'est ce que nous
avons fait au canada le vatican et u10
différents documents c'est dans ce
contexte le saint père
se prépare et il étudie la façon dont
l'église doit réagir à cela ça
n'arrivera peut-être pas aussi riche que
certaines personnes le pensent mais tout
cela demande du temps ce qui il faut
pouvoir bien comprendre et se donner je
ne réponse adéquate un peu comme les
évêques canadiens l'ont déjà fait pour
ce qui est de la visite pastorale bien
le pape l'a annoncé il a l'intention de
venir au canada
il en a parlé dans son allocution
aujourd'hui il a dit aux délégués
reconnu il admis ont exprimé le désir
qu'il a de rencontrer d'autres
communautés au canada
ces choses là sont en cours et cela
devrait nous donner espoir et nous
pouvons avoir confiance que ces
choses-là vance faire
céder
le pape a dit lui-même qu'il n'ira pas
en hiver
y aller autour de la fête de sainte-anne
à l'occasion du pèlerinage à sainte anne
est-ce que vous avez des indications
plus précises à combien d'endroits est
ce qu'il pourrait aller les dates la
durée peut-être de son voyage
justin avait trouvé intéressant qu'il
ait reçu des
raquettes
[Musique]
et parakou commence
ce genre de décisions concrètes
[Musique]
réalisées
ce
jeu
le chef antoine a utilisé le mot
génocide
est-ce que vous acceptez maintenant ce
mot est ce que l'église a participé un
génocide
ce que nous comprenons
de la vérité la réconciliation
ce qui a été compris quel est il
historique de succès passés dans les
systèmes de passionnant et les
corrigez-moi si nécessaire ça s'appelle
d'un génocide culturel donc il y avait
un adjectif qui se rajoutaient
c'est-à-dire de
d'affecter la culture la spiritualité la
langue ça oui
ces actions ont eu lieu dans le système
de passionnant et je pense que l'église
réalise
que ces réalités ont été retirés et si
nous décrivant cette action
en en parlant de génocide culturel mais
ça sous-entend une compréhension que le
gouvernement et les collaborateurs du
gouvernement tel que l'église ait
différentes dénominations religieuses
paix ça a été une participation de dents
lever les droits des gens la culture des
gens et la spiritualité des gens
nous écoutent un moniteur de votre six
décennies alors
le chef régional général antoine
le pape s'est excusé pour la conduite
des membres de l'église catholique mais
pas leur rôle que l'église a joué dans
le système de passionnés de vous cette
sélection
lubie de quoi vous s'il vous plaît à
répéter votre question alors le pape a
dit qu'il s'excuse pour la conduite des
membres de l'église catholique mais
qu'il ne ne sexy mais pas pour le rôle
de l'église pour ce qui est
du système des pensionnats êtes-vous
satisfait avec les mots du pape
a eu lieu je suis heureux d'entendre
cette question parce que
le système des pensionnats indiens
a dû venir de quelque part
oui
mon petit fils
m'a toujours
suggéré de poser la question pourquoi
quoi chagriner c'est la question que
nous devons nous demander afin de mieux
comprendre
[Musique]
les raisons du
système de la mise en oeuvre du système
des pensionnats et qu'il a
reflété un effort concerté
ce que je comprends c'est que
tokyo c'était pour tuer et l'indien dans
l'enfant et lorsqu'on pense au monde tu
es tu et reflète un crémant et lorsqu'on
lit la bible
il est écrit vous ne serez pas et si on
se penche sur les mots
c'est cela qu'on met en lumière
depuis bull et
les gens qui ont
commis ces crimes
doivent être tenus responsables et le
système également doit être tenu
responsable
le système qui a mis tout cela en oeuvre
et
pour en revenir à votre question
si on regarde le mot génocide
et on regarde la doctrine de la
découverte il y a eu
beaucoup de discussions de ce côté de
l'océan à savoir
comment aborder toutes ces questions
même s'il y avait deux représentants pas
de nos peuples mais deux représentants
qui nous représentait
mais collectivement
il y avait une entente
à savoir qu'on n'était pas des êtres
humains donc si on revient au mot
génocide
il ya eu des discussions
ici dans la communauté internationale
sur la portée de génocide du mot
génocide est ce que j'ai appris
c'est
dans ton commence à diluer la portée du
mot
étant donné comment on doit y faire face
laissez moi vous donner un exemple
la déclaration des nations unies sur les
droits des peuples autochtones
quand on la prend en considération
on sait que les peuples autochtones
étaient expliqués mais jusqu'à un
certain point et pensons à l'article 46
si on le regarde on voit
comment
tout cela entre dans un système et que
les choses sont une nébuleuse
que nous
terminons ce point de presse nous vous
invitons à exprimer
des derniers commentaires soit à tous
nos panélistes aujourd'hui il ya
beaucoup de travail qui a été fait il ya
trois ans pour arriver à ou nous en
sommes aujourd'hui et le travail demeure
à faire aussi
je pense que je loue tous deux vont
assurer que nous faisons tout ce que
nous pouvons possiblement faire pour les
survivants du système des pensionnats et
de leurs familles mais aussi que nous
prenions action
des actions qui assureront la vérité et
la justice
envers ceux qui ont encore
de très grand besoin
par rapport à tout ce qui s'est passé
alors
les pas le pape les évêques
les gens qui ont la foi à travers le
monde
peuvent contribuer à cette
réconciliation
la mettre de l'avant au nom des peuples
autochtones du canada et au canada aussi
il ya du travail que le gouvernement
peut faire il ya le travail que le
l'immédiat peuvent faire et que des
parties individuelles de l'église
catholique peuvent faire afin d'assurer
que les tensions derrière les mots du
pape
aujourd'hui est que les
intentions
exprimées par les médias
que cette question à même nos
communautés deviennent le fruit d'un
travail de collaboration alors que nous
avançons vers l'avenir il y a toujours
le on peut toujours prendre le temps de
respecter les droits humains s'excuser
lorsqu'il ya eu de l'abus et rechercher
la justice pour ceux qui le méritent
plus merci
madame caron
je pense que cette semaine réellement
démontré qu'il y a du pouvoir à raconter
nos histoires il ya du pouvoir derrière
notre vérité est ce que nous avons fait
cette semaine a été tout à fait
incroyable et nous savons que lorsque le
pape française tiendra au canada il
viendra avec une compréhension
approfondie une conscientisation
approfondie de qui nous sommes de ce qui
nous est arrivé nous les peuples des
premières nations et aussi l'espoir
quant à qui nous sommes et où nous
allons et c'est vrai pour nos enfants et
pour nos générations futures et c'est
pour eux aussi que nous faisons ce
travail ce qui a été très clair pour moi
cette semaine c'est que le pape françois
veut voir le changement est que nous
pouvons le faire ensemble que nous
pouvons créer un meilleur monde pour nos
générations futures et nous avons fait
prix des pas incroyable cette semaine en
ce sens l'action parle plus que les mots
et je pense que dans les jours les
viennent les jours les semaines les mois
et les années à venir les excuses ne
seront encore plus fortes lorsque nous
verrons ce qui se passe lorsque vous
lorsque nous verrons la guérison la
justice la responsabilisation lorsque
nous exprimerons notre vérité mais cela
dit aujourd'hui une étape incroyable
encore une fois j'aimerais vous
remercier tout un chacun pour être ici
afin de faciliter la transmission de nos
histoires et de pouvoir le transmettre
les transmettre au monde entier c'est
tellement important alors je termine
avec un message d'un de mes aînés qui
dit que la réconciliation n'a pas
commencé alors que nous sommes arrivés
au vatican et ne se termine pas ici cela
se terminera quand nos enfants
reviendront à la maison
merci chef antoine
aujourd'hui c'est une journée vraiment
spéciale
nous avons des grands parents des
parents et un
membre du système de pensionnat avec
nous aujourd'hui
et c'est une journée particulièrement
spéciale pour cet étudiant dont c'est
l'anniversaire aujourd'hui c'est will
roach heures dont je parle applaudissons
l'heure
[Applaudissements]
j'aimerais aussi le remercier
pour
tout ce qu'il représente en tant que
modèle et de mentors
et l'autre bonne nouvelle c'est que le
porte bébé traditionnel
est revenu ici
est un symbole applaudissons cela aussi
lorsque des gens collaborent ensemble
sur tous les membres d'une même famille
open et que ses membres s'ouvrent les
uns envers les autres cela crée une
relation toute spéciale
et cela commence avec de l'amour
vous avez peut-être entendu plus tôt
l'analogie de l'arbre notre famille
c'est comme les branches d'un arbre
nous poussons nous croissons dans des
directions différentes mais nos ratios
sont communes et plutôt notre aîné a
partagé
cette analogie 7 l'état fort de l'arbre
l'arbre fournit l'énergie
en reçoit du soleil de la pluie du vin
et s'en nourrit
qui a besoin de le faire donc
aujourd'hui une journée très spéciale
parce que nous avons
planter une graine
une graine
de soutien mutuel
d'énergie d'amour et aussi
de nourrir cette graine nous sommes là
pour la nourrir ensemble et en ce sens
je vous remercie d'être ici et de vous
ouvrir au travail qui a à faire nous
sommes venus ici avec coeur et nous
utilisons notre voie pour représenter
nos gens à la maison
encore une fois nous sommes venus ici
avec coeur avec amour dans un esprit de
collaboration
afin que le coeur reviennent chez soi
merci
le jour j 23 ans merci chef antoine
présidente qu'avant prise manteau beige
monsieur lévesque messieurs les évêque
monseigneur poisson on vous avez un mot
j'aimerais remercier
toutes les personnes qui ont participé à
ces délégations
l'ouverture des délégués
l'appui de leur organisation se fume
semaine intense une semaine importante
mais je voudrais aussi remercier par de
mémoire
en fait tous mes frères évêques au
canada qui participent à cette marche
ensemble vers la réconciliation je
voudrais aussi remercier tout le
personnel rattaché à cette conférence
parce que comme vous pouvez l'imaginer
ya beaucoup de courriels d'appel de
coordination qui doivent être faits avec
les gens du vatican pour que cela
devienne possible à l'heure je remercie
tout le monde merci beaucoup avant le
terminus
on aimerait éviter des légumes et 6 l
ferrari hier finale en gros et nous
aimerions aussi remercié les présidents
le représentant des évêques du canada
tous les représentants des délégations
nous savons à quel point vous avez été
occupé il ya eu l'idée requêtes venant
des médias par centaines
sachez qu'ils ont fait leur possible
pour répondre à toutes les questions qui
leur sont posées alors nous vous
remercions d'avoir raconté vos histoires
nous vous remercions de votre
accessibilité et il y aura sans aucun
doute d'autres chapitres à ce livre qui
s'ouvre alors que nous marchons ensemble
vers l'avenir alors j'inviterai
maintenant angie pour une prière de faim
hadji ne pas durer et à vous
tous merci
avant d'exprimer une prière j'aurai
quelques commentaires à faire
aujourd'hui
est une journée que je n'oublierai
jamais
il ya des choses qui ont commencé lundi
alors que nous étions en visite avec le
saint père est aujourd'hui
en fait mon coeur est tellement plein
que j'en perd pratiquement mémo non
seulement de recevoir
d'être reçu de lui parler je lui parlais
deux fois au sujet de nos enfants de
retrouver nos enfants et quand je lui ai
parlé lundi c'était quand je lui ai
parlé lundi et hier il se souvenait de
ce que je lui avais dit et je lui dis
saint-père n'oubliez pas nos enfants et
il m'a dit nous n'oublierons pas pour
moi c'est un rêve devenu réalité
non
notre non seulement de la part du pape
mais ce que j'ai ressenti c'était son
coeur son langage corporel sa vérité et
j'ai compris qu'il nous aime qui
qui nous dit qu'il est que nous sommes
dans son coeur et je sais pertinemment
que lorsqu'il viendra sur nos terres
qu'il sera le bienvenu
de la même manière qu'il nous a
accueilli cette semaine et je le
remercie
aujourd'hui cette semaine ça a été une
grande collaboration
il ya des choses qui reflète le travail
de plusieurs années les années récentes
et même plus longtemps mais nous
représentons nos peuples lorsque notre
chef s'exprimait il disait tout ce que
nous avons perdu nos terres nos
domiciles nos enfants
mais
qu'est ce qui a aussi être oublié
qu'est ce qui a aussi été oublié en fait
sommes-nous réellement séparer
aujourd'hui avant nous ont été séparés
précédemment nos coeurs nos âmes
sont ici sont ici
ensemble
et je me souviens en tant qu'enfant
comment nous nous nous aidions les uns
les autres nous étions là les uns pour
les autres et
d'avoir été séparés ne nous a pas aidés
il faut se rassembler de nouveau
retrouvé ce que nous avons perdu et je
vous encourage s'il vous plaît
regardez vos frères regardez vos soeurs
travailler ensemble soyez ensemble nous
savons nous savons
comment nous aimer nous savons comment
nous respecter et nous savons aussi
comment
nous pouvons
avoir confiance
exprimer
cette gentillesse qu'on nous a pris dès
notre plus tendre enfance
peut-être
tout ce que nous avons traversée
écoutez nous sommes encore ici nous
sommes fiers nous sommes heureux
et nous sommes ensemble et nous le
serons toujours je vous remercie
tellement d'être ici
d'apprendre ensemble et là nous
apprenons la confiance et nous
apprendrons avoir confiance ça se passe
pas dans le temps de le dire cela on le
sait la souffrance continue pour
tellement d'années
[Musique]
et nous devons le respecter et
n'oublions pas nos enfants nos enfants
sont précieux et trouvons leur
trouvant l'est alors seigneur cher
seigneur
je prie
et je prie que vous entendiez nos
prières alors qu'aujourd'hui nous
célébrons ensemble
alors que nous avons appris nous avons
appris que nous étions forts que nous
avions de l'espoir que nous avions des
rêves et que ceux ci sont devenus
réalité et nous serons plus forts que
jamais ensemble et ensemble nous
connaîtrons le succès nos enfants
comptent sur nous les enfants de nos
enfants ont besoin de nous
nous ne les laissez pas seuls
nous ne les avons jamais laissé seul et
nous ne le ferons et pourquoi ne le
ferions nous aujourd'hui c'est une
journée extraordinaire aujourd'hui
l'amour
exprimées par le pape
d'où nous donne l'élan de continuer à
travailler ensemble nous donne un élan
de sincérité
c'est tellement important pour nos gens
pour nos enfants notre petit enfant
et puis ce le monde savoir que nous
sommes
des hommes d'amour amen
qu'il faut quand même grave merci
beaucoup à tous d'avoir été ici merci à
tous les représentants des médias et
soyez saints et saufs dans votre retour
donc avec cette prière que se termine
cette semaine historique au vatican pour
les délégations des peuples autochtones
du canada alors je retrouve mes invités
isabelle picard est no log marbre de la
nation huronne wendat et alain pronkin
spécialiste des questions religieuses on
entendu beaucoup de choses évidemment
dans cette conférence de presse là mais
je retiens je pense que c'est monsieur
antoine qui dit le chef antoine qui
disait on accepte de ses excuses lors
comme étant un geste de bonne foi et on
a eu l'impression que le pape était
encore plus sincère parce qu'il nous a
écouté toute la semaine il a entendu les
témoignages et là ses excuses venait
vraiment de son coeur et c'est un peu ce
que dit aussi monseigneur grattan je
penserai à vous entendre tous les deux
là dessus d'abord isabelle
oui enfin ce qui le dit je pense
monsieur antoine c'est j'ai bien aimé la
métaphore il a dit c'est comme si on
avait des traces comme quand on voit la
chasse mais on n'est pas arrivé à une
finalité donc pour moi c'est un départ
encore leur le dit et ce que je retiens
beaucoup de ce que les trois personnes
les trois représentants un délégué on
dit c'est la notion de travail cette
affaire oui cette notion-là de travail
qui est à faire avec l'église mais qui
est à faire aussi entre nous et de façon
individuelle et communautaire pour se
guérir il ce besoin de justice également
qui est qui est important et de
reconnaissance des faits et de la vérité
c'est prochaine oui moi si j'avais
remarqué au courant de la semaine qu' il
y avait deux cardinaux canadien de
cardinal czerny et le cardinal ouellet
qui ont accompagné des délégations à
certaines occasions et on sait que ces
deux cardinaux leur ont conseillé le
pape immédiatement après la découverte
des corps à kamloops de mémoire ou celui
à marie vague dont ils ont été consultés
ils sont présents ils savent ce qui se
passe et rappelons que de crise en voie
d'être déjà déclaré il ya plusieurs
années les les était indifférente face
aux premières nations on a aussi le
cardinal dacquois l'archevêque de québec
qui a déclaré oui on est complice de ça
en parlant de ce qui est arrivé dans les
pensionnats des premières nations donc
aussi que les cardinaux canadien ça
c'est important parce qu'on n'a pas trop
parlé vont faire partie de ce mouvement
elles vont faire partie de cette marche
de cette de cette recherche de la
sincérité qui était essentielle dans les
prochaines démarches de seul quand vous
organisez qu'on n'a pas entendu c'est
celui toronto j'espère qu'il va se lier
avec ses trois autres confrères mais
c'est la démarche est enclenché on sait
déjà que le camion doit d'être prête au
québec où courant de l'été normale va et
vient pour rencontrer sa famille il nous
a déjà indiqué qu'ils avaient
l'intention d'accompagner le pape
lorsqu'il viendrait au canada donc la
table est mise la sincérité doivent être
démontrée et si ce qui s'en vient dans
les prochains jours et on a ou encore eu
la réclamation des idiots et dalsa il ya
d'autres religieux qui ont commis des
agressions sur nos enfants et ont plus
que justice soit faite vis-àvis
vis-à-vis ces gens là donc les premières
démarches sont déjà entreprises suite
aux premiers pas conduit ce matin
acceptable alors ça ça va se passer
quelque part mais pas en hiver
idéalement à la demande
du québec et monsieur antoine qui disait
aussi le chef antoine il va venir à la
maison il va venir parler à nos familles
et ça c'est vraiment aussi très très
important on parle beaucoup d'une
semaine historique je vous laisse le mot
de la fin isabelle piquant c'est
vraiment historique ce qui s'est passé
oui absolument c'est historique même au
début de la semaine il ya des gens qui
n'y croyaient pas encore j'ai entendu
phil fontaine qui faisait tant que j'ai
pas eu le discours dans mes mains que je
n'ai pas lu limoges je n'y croyais vous
croyez presque pas ou à peine donc il
s'est passé quelque chose je pense
qu'une grande écoute et ça va
réconforter je pense les survivants des
pensionnats et tous les descendants
aussi puisqu'on l'a 10 et
multigénérationnel donc un grand début
on va voir la suite et cette survivante
nos enfants qui sont précieux il faut
vraiment en prendre soin merci beaucoup
de vos lumières isabelle picard est no
log membres de la nation des hurons
wendat à québec alain prokin spécialiste
des questions religieuses mais
infiniment merci au revoir leur chez
vous
alors cette cérémonie évidemment elle
était très suivi par les communautés
autochtones au pays et bon 16 et ceux
qui sont restés ici
gabriel vous êtes journaliste un espace
autochtone alors comment on réagit ainsi
au canada bien faut dire que d'abord
c'est très bien accueilli ces excuses du
pape parce qu'elle était attendue depuis
de très nombreuses années
non seulement par les survivants des
pensionnats et leurs familles mais aussi
par l'ensemble des communautés parce que
les conséquences que les passionnants
ont eu beau se font sentir dans
l'ensemble des communautés encore
aujourd'hui le consensus c'est que c'est
une première étape une première étape
vers des actions concrètes pour la
guérison et la réconciliation on peut
penser entre autres à l'ouverture des
archives de l'église afin de pouvoir
faire toute la lumière sur ce qui est
arrivé aux enfants sont décédés qu'on ne
peut retrouver qui ont été au pensionnat
mais par contre aussi on peut on peut
penser à aller un peu plus loin parce
que non de son allocution le pape
beaucoup parlé de colonialisme et il
faut se rappeler que les délégations
autochtone souhaité que le vatican
révoque formellement le concept la
doctrine du terra nullius qui a été
adoptée par l'église au moyen âge et
cette doctrine la a été utilisée pour
justifier la colonisation des amériques
et de l'afrique en disant ce n'est pas
un territoire
vraiment habitée parce qu'il n'y a pas
d'état il n'y a pas d'état catholique
donc les colonisateurs européens peuvent
prendre ce territoire donc en demandant
la révocation de cette doctrine de
l'église reconnaîtrait sa responsabilité
dans la colonisation en entier ce qui
serait pour rien là dessus je vous
invite à écouter la sénatrice michèle
audette qui était à l'émission tout au
matin on peut maintenant assurer que nos
leaders vont parler avec les gens et
revoir et redéfinir quelle a été la
fameuse terra nullius je suis arrivé en
premier donc ça m'appartient où il ya
juste moi qui habite ce grand territoire
et bien sûr je ne souhaite
collectivement avoir accès aux archives
du côté des survivants les exclus sont
effectivement bien accueillis par contre
avec certaine déception certains
survivants auraient voulu que le pape
soit un peu plus crue dans ses mots en
parlant vraiment des vies perdues des
vies d'enfants perdus dans les
pensionnats au cours des décennies qui
l'ont été ils ont été ouverts au canada
puis en fait on est vraiment impatient
pour les surveillants sont vraiment
impatient de savoir ce qu'ils voient est
fait par la suite puis commun comment la
société va gérer toute cette vérité
c'est dans la formulation béa la phrase
des excuses qui me qui me déçoit
beaucoup
parce que il a oublié quand même
certains détails importants donc la
découverte d'ailleurs des corps
d'enfants à kamloops qu'est ce qu'on
fait pour ceux et celles qui ont commis
les crimes ce et des crimes qui ont été
commis un vin nos familles ceux qui ont
fréquenté les enfants qui ont fait entre
les pensionnats les gens afin qu'ils ne
sont jamais retourner dans leur famille
c'est ça qui rase encore
1 au moment où je parle qu'elle est
quelle est la suite à donner posté au
ces criminels il va falloir utiliser les
vrais moore
avait beaucoup d'attentes certaines
demandes précises aussi selon les
délégations et de ces demandes qui est
pas encore été mentionné par le passé
cette question des artefacts tout à fait
c'était une des demandes principales des
délégations autochtone cette semaine à
savoir que les artefacts qui proviennent
de communautés autochtones du canada qui
se trouve au vatican soient rapatriés
dans leur communauté d'origine
les délégations pu visiter le musée du
vatican cette semaine il ya beaucoup de
beaucoup des gens qui ont été présents
qui ont été déçus de voir comment ces
objets souvent très important
spirituellement traditionnellement on
était entre nu entreposés au fil des
années surtout que la façon dont le
basque a obtenu ces gens vivent ces
objets de dommages assez flou donc reste
à voir si les communautés vont
entreprendre les démarches afin de
récupérer ces objets même si il ya peu
il y en a pas été question par le pape
aujourd'hui ce n'était que le début de
cette marche sur le chemin de la
réconciliation c'est ce qu'ont répété
les membres de la délégation des
différentes délégations merci qu'après
ça me fait plaisir à voir au revoir
et juste être dos à ce père est lui
aussi des excuses du vatican valérie il
a d'ailleurs réagi sme et lui a parlé
d'un pas vers l'avant et a rappelé que
depuis des décennies donc les inuits
limiter ces les premières nations du
canada demandé espérait ses excuses et
il a souligné le courage d'ailleurs des
survivants qui au fil des années ont
témoigné et a dit que sans leurs
témoignages jamais peut-être ses excuses
aujourd'hui aurait eu lieu un premier
ministre avait dit aux jo plus tôt cette
semaine qui croyait qu'il était temps
est important que le chef de l'église
donc présente ses excuses aux nations
autochtones du canada est ce matin
justin trudeau participé d'ailleurs une
conférence de presse aux côtés du
premier ministre du nunavut pour une
annonce finalement d'approvisionnement
en eau parce que la pensée eu de gros
problèmes d'eau potable et c'est à ce
moment qu'il a réagit donc à ses excuses
présentées par françois le pape je
laisse entendre que juste être doivent
être
aujourd'hui le pape françois a présenté
ses excuses pour le rôle de l'église
dans les abus qui ont eu lieu dans les
pensionnats autochtones
c'est une étape importante
notre gouvernement va continuer de
soutenir les communautés autochtones à
travers le pays avec les ressources
nécessaires pour poursuivre les
recherches des tombes anonymes dévoiler
la vérité et continuer à guérir
et puis pour ce qui est de ce que le
gouvernement du canada lui confère
encore au cours des prochains moins bien
il a dit qu' ils s'engageaient à
continuer de soutenir les communautés
autochtones dans leur recherche de
sépulture sur les lieux donc d'anciens
pensionnaires catholique autochtones
partout au pays plus tôt à cette semaine
d'ailleurs il était à william blake eux
ou à la mission à saint-joseph là bas au
cours des derniers mois on a découvert
93 tombe non marquées et il a annoncé du
financement hauteur de 2,4 millions de
dollars justement pour poursuivre ses
recherches autour de cet ancien
pensionnat autochtone justin trudeau a
rappelé que c'est important cette étape
de deuil il faut accompagner les
communautés autochtones là-dedans
important donc de les écouter important
de leur fournir aussi tout le soutien
elle gérait technique parce que ce sont
des fous est extrêmement complexe à
réaliser donc de l'argent qui ira
vraiment pour soutenir toutes les
communautés partout au canada merci
valérie au repas
alors rester là après la pause on va
faire le tour de l'actualité en pro tour
le point sur la pandémie de kobe 19 au
canada
[Musique]